nora good morning how are you doing good
morning john can you hear me all right i
can hear you
perfectly what's going on well
first off thank you for uh taking the
call absolutely thanks for calling in
um and i wrote it down so i could be
very precise
son senior in high school diagnosed with
add
third and between third and fourth grade
also diagnosed with anxiety
has an iep has a therapist had all the
special education teachers
and some were good some were bad and
no matter what we did it still seems
like they're making him
feel like it's just sort of glossed over
his add
and so now that he's a senior in high
school he's you know
kind of miserable and i don't feel like
he's
learned the executive skill set that he
needs and
i actually started to resent it somewhat
but your broadcast where you had the
um the adult add and his wife
uh really spoke to me and that's when i
was able to release that resentment so
i'm
trying to help him now what can i do
awesome so walk me back to
your beautiful little boy at third grade
fourth grade what
what was going on in your heart and mind
that let you know
he's struggling well we were blessed uh
my husband is the son of educators okay
and my husband has some anxiety issues
as well so we could spot it pretty
easily and our
our oldest son and so we
on privately had testing done between
the two years
but we also what about what caused the
testing what was going on in your
in your son's life that made you think
he needs to be tested for something
oh um he was very sensitive
in third grade they think thinking that
he had something wrong with him they put
him in this class
with a with people who weren't being
looked after if you know what i mean
they
had issues but for whatever the reason
the family wasn't available or whatever
i don't know
but it was he is like in kindergarten
he would cry that was normal
later on he would cry and that wasn't
normal or considered normal
and so he switched it to anger so there
was
a difficulty being able to
manage whatever stimuli
was in front of him and if he was very
frustrated
um and then my husband looked at it and
said we are pulling him out
we're going to send him over we're
getting into better school
and then also we had him tested and we
had um you know
we moved forward from there so what was
going on in your home environment during
that time
like when i think of anxiety i just it's
it's an alarm system
when i think of adhd it is just a
biological and neurological response
it's a natural response to chaos
um what was going on in y'all's home and
this isn't an accusation this is just a
mining process we're just going for a
walk together in the woods what was
going on there that
that let this little boy not feel like
it could be heard or feel like he was
disconnected what was going on there
well there wasn't anything in particular
we were living in a townhouse and
and everything was reasonably okay we
were concerned for him
because of this but i mean from the day
he was born he was always sensitive
okay um and to be honest
i don't know if you want to go there but
we've i feel like he's an
empath as well um i don't know if that
makes it worse or not but we can move on
from there um
but the environment i mean it was more
stimulated
because we were near a highway um
but otherwise but you told me you told
me his dad was anxious
so
he went to a therapist and was on
medication and is still on medication
and still
does the therapist so what i'm what i'm
trying to back out is
less um please hear me here and everyone
listening to this
um i've i've met with folks who just
break down in tears when we have these
conversations
and it's not about accusations
it's about awareness right it's not
about blame it's about trying to
just say oh okay i see that um because
that's the only way we're gonna solve
the problem down the stream here
um so if you got a doubt with anxiety
how does dad deal with
stress does he disconnect does he get
loud does he go for walks what does dad
do for
for stress management um
i would say that he disconnects okay
more than anything um
in the same room but that's yeah that's
and
that's the way i do it and i have found
over the years
that may be the most insidious way
because when somebody disappears out the
front door
you know there's a break you know
they're gone
when somebody's with you it's like um
it's like almost this ghosting
gaslighting
i'm with you but i'm completely
disconnected from you and it makes
people feel
crazy um because they you're with them
in body but you're not with them in
spirit how do you deal with stress and
frustration
how do you deal with anxiousness yeah
you
i'm still working on it how do you deal
with it
oh i i somewhat disconnect as well okay
so take me back to 15 years ago what was
going on in y'all's world where
something would come home your husband
would get frustrated or he would take
some medication he would sit like a
zombie
or a disconnected person who's with
everybody in the living room
and then you come in and things haven't
been done you're frustrated
what's your what's your internal
response or external response
well first off we i was at home
i was an at-home mother okay great so
when dad would come in he would talk to
me
he would play he would play with kids he
would play with the dog
um and then he would sort of check out
you know we would have dinner
sure um
you know i i really want to answer your
questions but i'm not sure i
know the answers well that's oh and
again i'm just trying to
give myself a um some some breadcrumbs
to follow here into the woods
so fast forward to me now you've got a
son how old is he
17 17. so he's is he a senior now is he
a junior now
um he's a senior okay so this is his
last year before he starts heading out
so what does anxiety look like for him
now what does adhd look like for him now
um you know you're talking about
checking out he uses the computer to
check out
okay and that's pretty much his only
thing
although he does do a little gardening
in terms of adhd it's a lot of anxiety
it's a lot of trying to figure out how
to do work without having a bunch of
people nag him
because to be honest that's what the
school system did they basically
just nagged him to get his work done and
i
i feel like that's not really teaching
executive skills
how did you guys support him
we did what we could i tried to learn
what i could but i tried to rely on the
school system because i didn't want to
get in
you know it's that catch-22 you want to
help
but you also don't want to enter you
know
get in the way of what excuse me what
the professionals should be doing
and but the and now that he's in high
school he has
um his special ed teacher and the guy is
really really nice
but he's not teaching any skill sets
that my son really needs
so so listen a lot of a lot of your
response is super common for folks with
special needs kids
for for folks with young kids or for
older kids who are they are just butting
heads with or they are just kind of at a
loss
okay but every time i'm asking you a
question
you're pointing to somebody else as the
problem and so i want to get from you
is over the last 10 years over the last
five years over the last five
months how are you encouraging him to
get his work done
how are you reconnecting with him how
are you setting up situations where
those alarms are going to come down
because here's the deal anxiety adhd
those are contexts they're not an excuse
you still got to get your work done
sure right you still gotta go do those
things
and blaming all these external systems
while it's real
it's hard and it's annoying some schools
are super equipped
some teachers are extraordinary
some maybe aren't nobody can replace the
mom and dad in this situation
and so what your school system isn't
going to solve this problem at age 17
the healing is going to come from you
but it's got to start with you being
reflective
saying what am i bringing to this
situation because it's my
son so i only can talk to you joey and
you're the only one on the phone with me
when when your son is struggling when he
is like having mythical thinking about
time
or he is real frustrated because he's
procrastinating again or he can't find
his hat
again or his keys are missing again how
do you
participate in what happens next
um for the last couple of years i think
it's been difficult to be patient
but at the same time i am his sounding
board i am the one he comes to
i do work with him as best i can i also
work with the school system uh to see
i was writing emails going give me
advice tell me what to do
you know talk to the administration who
anybody i could talk to
to get uh more insight into what to do
now the
these two years were the hardest it
turns out that the
my son the freshman year in the
sophomore year nick
my son was doing much better
really grasping really enjoying school
and school was done
at school and then home was home
and then the way they have it set up
here the the uh
junior year for whatever the reason is
meant to be the hardest
and so it really taxed all of his
abilities
and we got tutors and we got you know
whatever we needed
but it was very hard for him and then of
course covid came in
and and it was everything turned upside
down
but but listen heart is a good thing
heart is a great thing it can be
challenging and some schools can be
failure factories
but hard is not a bad thing taking a kid
who is able to skate through his
freshman and sophomore year
and then runs up against the brick wall
that is your junior year that's pre-cal
that's all that
you know that's getting into some really
complex things it's it's
getting past the social studies stories
and now we're getting to the
the depth that's good stuff
and when a kid runs up against
hard and we're in a system where it's
like man the school's not helping enough
or we've got to fill in the blank xyz
we've got to get this expert and that
expert
walk me through what is it that makes
you uncomfortable about your kids
struggling right now
because he should be he's a senior in
high school i want that to be hard
because then next year is going to be
college and that's going to be real hard
it's living with it it's making sure
that he has what he needs
um he doesn't want us to do things it's
that that age
where he doesn't want us to okay you're
on you're on it now joanne you're on it
okay
listen my name is norah okay oh nora i'm
so sorry
it's okay we'll go back i keep going
joanna um
all right so you're on it nora you're on
it so here's the thing
you are uncomfortable with how he's
struggling how is he doing
well he doesn't like it either obviously
of course he doesn't he's not supposed
to but how is he doing i'm not sure
um we are about to approach midterms
and he doesn't he's not telling us
anything you know i ask him so i ask him
broader questions like okay
are you getting things done is you know
is there anything i need to be concerned
with
is there anything you need you know help
with or you know and so forth like that
i ask those kinds of questions
so they're broader so it's a little bit
easier for him to answer
without getting into the weeds because
he doesn't want to tell me the weeds
okay so
here's the deal noor he doesn't get a
choice
and you don't get a choice okay
he doesn't get a choice you don't get a
choice he's your kid and he's at home
hard is good for kids it's good for them
and when parents rush in to try to swoop
and save them
it undermines their efficacy it
undermines
their ability to think about how good
they're going to be at something
it undermines their ability to fail and
realize that's not the end of the world
it sounds like you're the one in this
discomfort gap
you're the one that doesn't like to see
your kids struggling with
and he's strong and he's since he was
little since he came
out of the womb
you guys have labeled him as sensitive
as needing a little extra help
as somebody who needs a diagnosis
as somebody who needs he's probably
going to need he cries a lot he's a
little bit more sensitive
and instead of owning that relationally
it sounds like there's just been this
gap where it's that's a problem that's a
thing we've got to fix we got to get
special people here we got to do special
things here
and now he's 17 and you still are
feeling this
weight on your heart in your mind and so
asking generalized questions to a kid
that's had
um learning challenges asking
broad questions no man you've got to get
in
the middle of it nora you've got to take
him out
forget about the assignments forget all
that stuff you got to take him out and
say
how are you doing i am your mom i am
forcing you to talk to me
you have to be in my life you have to be
in my heart you've got to let me know
what's going on in your heart and i'm
going to talk to you and so if we're
just going to go for a walk
every night great i'm going to make you
hold my hand
because i am your freaking mom and moms
all across the country are laughing at
me right now and i do not care
you're going to tell your son you've got
to hold my hand because i'm your mom and
you have to
my mom is 70 years old and when i see
her she says
you have to hug me and i'm going to
anyway but she just gets to say that
because i'm her
kid i'm her son so a 17 year old doesn't
get
vague questions a 17 year old that
you're worried about
um you're worried about how they're
processing things you're worried about
their anxiety
their disconnection they don't get
generalized questions they get specific
show me your work today and is it a pain
oh my gosh yes
having kids is hard is it a struggle yes
but what's going to happen is you're
going to not say you're going to you're
going to spend a semester
what's going to happen is you're going
to spend a semester saying how are
things going
you got your assignments done and your
kid's going to go yeah got it
i'm good and then you're just going to
go back to the computer and the next day
how's everything going good fine and
then you're going to keep going they're
going to keep going
and then you're going to get to midterms
and they're going to have four zeros
and two c's and what you're going to do
is get mad and you're going to call the
school
and you're going to say nobody called me
nobody did this nobody
it's your responsibility but it starts
not with the assignments it starts not
with the diagnosis
it starts not with the other people
or challenges it starts not with my kids
broken
it starts with hey good boy good morning
how are you
hey good boy i love you come over here
and give me a hug before the day even
starts
it starts with hey what's today going to
look like
what's one awesome thing you're going to
think about before you leave
it starts with have you got your
homework done yet because we got our
nightly walk and we do not miss nightly
walk time
it starts with if you don't get off that
computer i'm going to throw it off the
roof
and we're going to watch it smash into a
million pieces because my relationship
with you
is more important than you plugging into
some dumb box
and i know this is hard i was an 80d kid
i was an
anxious kid i still struggle with
anxiety now
it's a conscious constant battle that i
gotta stay in front of
i've worked with countless college
students
high school students struggle with atd
anxiety
and it usually starts
from chaos in the home disconnection in
the home
moms and dads who are trying just to
keep things plugged in this isn't a
blame conversation this is
hard
parents who are just trying to get the
bills paid parents who are just trying
to get to tomorrow they're dealing with
their own junk that their parents gave
to them and that their parents gave to
them
or that their community gave to them or
their country gave to them however that
works
but when you start at age four telling a
kid that hey you may be broken
you're probably need some special stuff
they're gonna live into that and if you
do have a kid with special needs
stay on top of those teachers stay on
top of those
those professionals who live in those
worlds and never
ever ever think to yourself well i don't
want to get involved
get involved get involved
one of the the terms i hate the most
is the term helicopter parent i hate it
i hate it i hate it and here's why
your kid is the most precious thing on
planet earth to you
it does not ever
occur to me to not get involved with my
kids ever
i just i worked at colleges for years i
loved it when parents called that meant
that they cared about their kid
but moms and dads
brothers and sisters
you gotta let your kids fail too you
gotta let them experience consequences
too there's a difference between saying
hey i'm worried about my son are they
okay
and this is your fault
this is your fault norah i know you love
your boy i want you to back out
i want you to back way out 30 000 feet
you got a year left with him or now
you're down to nine months before he
goes to college
or who knows how long cove it's going to
last maybe he's going to live at home
for the next few years
for the next 30 days i want you to tell
them you talked to some knucklehead on
the radio
who said every morning we have to start
the morning with a hug
every morning we have to start with me
looking you in the eyes and telling you
i love you and i'm so glad you're my son
every morning you start with i'm so glad
that people in the world were made to
feel like you do
every morning you talk about hey what's
today's plan i want you to make a list
with him this is going to be for 30 days
you're going to be annoyed by this by
the end of it
make a plan for today when he gets home
at the end of that day
i want you to say what's one awesome
thought you had today
at the end of the day i want you to hug
him before you start talking to him
about school work
at the end of the day i want you to say
what assignments do you have today that
you need to get done
how can i help you i want to see them
before you're done
and before you get on the computer we go
on for our walks and that means we don't
get on the computer night that means we
don't get on the computer tonight
we're going to go out and garden
together we're going to go out and kick
the soccer ball i'm going to go and do
some stuff together
and i want you to try to put the
assignments down
the well what about what i want you to
try connecting
try connecting first
just try for 15 years you've tried other
things try this
and that's not a matter of coming in and
playing with the dog and saying i want
you to connect connect
connect and nora i want to to honor you
for being a mom that still cares about
her kid who still loves her kid he's
still trying to figure it out he's not
giving up on their 17 year old and their
18 year old
millions of parents do thank you for
being a parent that cares
take full full ownership of your boy
and start with connecting he's worth it